What we're doing today is
continuing on the theme of emotions.
Emotions is a two part lecture.
Um,
and we're continuing along certain themes.
I want to begin by responding
to a question which was
raised in the last class
concerning smiling in nonhuman primates.
It was a very good question.
The issue was,
um,
we know that humans have different sorts
of smiles to convey different sorts of
information.
The question was,
do nonhuman primates like chimpanzees or
gorillas or Gibbons have the same many
sorts of smiles?
So I contacted the world's expert on
smiling who did not return my emails.
So I contacted the second world's
expert on smiling who, um,
who told me that answer's no, that, um,
that primate nonhuman primates smiles
actually correspond almost entirely to
appeasement smiles there.
Don't hurt me. Smiles. Um,
they're equivalent to the Koi
smile that we saw in humans. Um,
but that nonhuman primates do
not use smiles for greetings.
There's no equivalent of the greeting,
smile or Pan Am smile,
nor do they use them as genuine
expressions of happiness.
There's no equivalent to the Duchenne
smile. So that's as far as I know.
If the world's expert gets back to
me and says something different, um,
I'll keep you posted. Uh, another thing,
going back to the beginning
theme of the class, um,
w what we started just to review,
we talked about the different functions
of emotions and then we talked about
smiling and facial expressions and then
we turned to some nut to a nonsocial
motion,
the case of fear.
And then we shifted to social emotions
and we talked about social emotions
towards kin and a special evolutionary
reasons that would lead them to evolve.
Um, and as we were ending,
we were talking about, um,
about the relationship between
an animal and its children,
particularly in cases like humans and
birds and mammals where there tends to be
a close relationship with our trailer.
We invest in quality, not quantity. Um,
I might produce very few
children in my life, uh,
and my evolutionary trick then is to
focus very intently on them and make sure
they survive. If I were to produce a 100
children, I could stand to lose a few.
But if I just produced five
in my lifetime or two or one,
they become very precious
to me. And so, um,
the story of the evolution of species
like us involves a long period of
dependence and deep, deep bonds
between the parent and the child.
And that's part of what I talked
about how parents respond to children.
And I want to begin this class by,
by giving a,
an illustration from a documentary
about parental response to children.
But I want to give it a
species that's not us.
And here's why.
I'll explain why with an analogy.
I have a friend of mine who
studies the psychology of religion.
You studies why people
hold religious beliefs.
And he tells me that when he's
talking to a non specialist,
somebody not in the field, he
doesn't ever tell them. Yeah,
I'm really interested in
why people believe in the
Bible or why people light the
candles on Sabbath are
why people go to church.
Cause these are religions
that people around here hold.
And if you tell people you study them,
belts would be puzzled.
Why would you want to study
something like that or a or offended?
If you want to talk about the psychology
of religion to an audience like this,
what you do is you start with the exotic.
So you start by talking about people
who um, who put butter under heads.
There's a Dan Sperber talks
about a culture where the
men put butter under heads
in the summer and a kind of melts and
that's part of one of the things that they
do. Or do you talk about, um,
about a culture that believes in
spirits or that trees can talk.
You say you're setting, they
say, oh, that's interesting.
I wonder why they believe that.
And you use that as a way
to look at more general, uh,
facts that exist even in our culture.
You use the fact that,
that we don't take the exotic for granted
as a way to motivate the scientific
study of things we do take for granted.
And this is of course true more generally.
This was the point in the William James
quote when he talked about things that
are natural to us and notice that some
very odd things are equally natural to
other species.
And it's true,
I think in particular when we talk about
things like the love we have for our
children.
Um,
so one way to look at the love we have
for our children scientifically isn't to
look at it head on because the love we
feel towards their own children feel
sacred if feel special,
but look at it in other species.
And so one of the nicest illustrations
of this is to emperors a penguin,
um, which was, uh, which,
whose childcare and mating practices were
dramatized in a wonderful movie called
March of the penguins. Um, and um,
this is interesting because they had
this incredibly elaborate and quite
precarious system of generating
and taking care of offspring.
So I want to show you a brief clip of the
movie to illustrate some parts of this.
Um, what they do at the beginning, which
is not, which leads up to this is, um,
they take a very long trek from the
water to their breeding grounds.
Their breeding grounds is protect our,
protected from the wind and are on a
firm piece of ice so they could hold a
whole pack. They do the breeding there
and it's there that the eggs are created.
So this is where, um, the
movie begins at this point.
March of the penguins was the second best,
second most popular
documentary of all time, um,
beaten only by Fahrenheit
nine, 11. And, um,
and people responded to it in
different ways, which are informative.
When we think about the
generalizations you can make, uh,
from animal behavior to human behavior.
Some conservative commentators saw this
as a celebration of family values such
as love and trust and monogamy.
Um,
some liberals who hate everything
that's good and true, uh,
responded, responded by saying, well, yet,
or monogamous for one breeding season,
it's a year. Then they go and find another
mate. You add it up. It's pretty slutty.
Um,
I think more to the point,
people were impressed and stunned by
the rich and articulate and systematic
behavior that these animals
were showing plainly.
They didn't pick it up from
television, movies, culture,
learning, schooling. So on,
to some extent this sort of complicated
behavior came natural to them.
And it's understandable that some
proponents of intelligent design or
creationism pointed to
this as an example of,
of how God creates things that are deeply,
richly intricate so as to perpetrate
the survival of different animals.
From a Darwinian standpoint.
Either Darwinian would
agree with the creationist.
It is, couldn't have happened by accident.
This is just far too complicated,
but would appeal to the,
um,
to this as an exquisite example of a
biological adaptation in particular,
a biological adaptation regarding parental
care to children shaped by the fact
that children share the parents' genes.
And so parents will evolve in ways
that perpetrate the survival of their
children.
Then there's the other direction,
which is how children
respond to parents, how, um,
how the young ones are wired
up to resonate and respond
in different ways to the
adults around them.
And we quickly talked about about
some different theories of this. Um,
and I'll just review what we
talked about last class. Um,
babies will develop an
attachment to whoever's closest.
They'll usually prefer their mothers
because their mothers are typically those
who are closest to them to prefer
her voice, her face, her smell. Um,
it used to be thought that there's some
sort of magical moment of imprinting
that when the baby is born, the baby
must see his or her mother and boom,
a connection is made.
If the baby doesn't terrible,
things will happen with attachment
later on. This is silly.
There's no reason to believe there's some
special moment or special five minutes
or special hour.
It's just in the fullness of time,
babies will look up an attachment
to the animal that's closest to it.
They will recognize it as at a,
at an implicit level,
at an unconscious level as their
kin. Well, how does this work?
How does the baby's brain develop come
to develop an emotional attachment to,
to that creature?
Well,
you remember from Skinner that operant
conditioning could provide a good answer
to this. And this is a known
as the cupboard theory,
which is babies love their moms
because the moms provide food.
So law of effect is
operating conditioning. Um,
they will approach their mothers to get
the food from them and they will develop
an attachment because
their mother provides food.
And this is contrasted
with a more nativist,
hardwired theory developed by a Bowlby,
which claims that there's
two things going on.
There is a drawn to mum for comfort
and social interaction and afraid of
strangers.
Now in the real world it's difficult to
pull apart these two means of attraction
because the very same woman
who's giving you comfort and um,
and social interaction because
also the one giving you milk,
but in the laboratory
you can pull them apart.
And that's what Henry Harlow did
in the movies you saw last week.
So Harlow exposed primates
to two different mothers.
One is a wire mother that's a Skinnerian
mother, that's a mother who gave food,
the other's a cloth mother set up
so that she'd be comfortable and,
and give warmth and cuddling. And the
question is, which one do babies go for?
And as you can remember from the movies,
the results are fairly decisive.
Babies go to the wire,
mother, uh, to eat. Yes.
As one of the characters
said you got to eat to live.
But they viewed the day
they loved the cloth mother.
They develop an attachment to the warm
cuddly mother that that's the one they
use as a base.
When they were threatened,
that's the one they use as a
base from which to explore.
Okay. And that actually,
oh, that's just a picture.
Um, and that actually takes me
to the, Oh, except for one thing,
it almost takes me to the end of the
question of our emotions towards Ken.
Um, one question you could ask is
what if there's no contact at all?
Now you could imagine that the effects
of how a lot of people are interested in
the question of the effects of the child's
early relationship to adults around
him or her and how the
child turns out later.
This becomes hugely relevant for
social debates like daycare. So,
for instance, a lot of psychologists
are interested in the question,
is it better for a child
to be raised by a parent,
usually a mother,
or does it make a difference
if the child goes to daycare?
What if a child goes to
daycare at six months?
What if child goes to daycare at two
years? How does this affect the child?
The short answer,
nobody really knows.
There's a lot of debate over whether or
not there's subtle differences and it's
deeply controversial. But we do know
that it doesn't make a big difference.
We do know that, that if, um,
if you got raised by mom or perhaps mum
and dad or maybe just dad all through
your life until going up for school and I,
my parents threw me in a
daycare at a three months, um,
it's not gonna make a big difference for
us. Maybe a subtle difference though.
It's not clear which way it would go,
but it won't make a big difference.
But what if there's no
contact at all? What if, um,
what about terrible circumstances
where people get no cloth mother,
they get nobody for attachment.
This is a really, in the
real world, of course,
you can't do experiments on this.
And in the real world with humans,
this only happens in tragic cases.
Um,
but this has been studied. Um, so,
so Harlow again,
raise monkeys and solitary confinement.
So they were, they were, um,
race and steel cages with only
a wire mother. In other words,
they got older nutrition they needed,
but they got no mothering.
It turned out that,
um,
that you kind of get monkey psychotics,
they're withdrawn, they don't
play, they bite themselves.
Um, they're incompetent
sexually. They're in socially,
they're incompetent. Maternally
in one case, one of these monkeys,
race and college, Harry confinement was
artificially inseminated. Um, when she,
um, when she had a child, she, um,
banged his head on the floor
and in bid it to death.
So you need to be,
you need this shows.
This is kind of a stark demonstration
that some early connections,
some early attachment is critical
for the developing of a primate.
Um, obviously you don't do
these experiments with people,
but there are natural experiments.
Um,
humans raised in harsh orphanages
with little social contact.
And, um, and these children, Dave,
if the, if the, in other words,
they get fed barely, but nobody
picks them up and cuddles them. Um,
these children, if this
happens for long enough, um,
they ended up with severe problems with
social and emotional development. Um,
from an emotional point of view.
They're often insatiable.
Like they really need cuddling
and support or they're apathetic.
They don't care at all.
Now there's some sort of good news,
which is if you get these people
or these monkeys early enough, um,
you can reverse the effects
of this bad development.
So there's some research done
with monkey therapists. So anyway,
they do is they take the monkey,
they raised in a steel cage to monkey,
comes out the monkeys kind of psycho,
and then they send in a younger
monkey who's just goofing around,
jumping all around the place
and, and, and everything.
And experience with this younger monkey
who just follows him around and cleaning
to them, um, leads to gradual improvement.
It makes the solitary
monkey become better. Um,
there might be a similar
effect with human.
So one story more about of an anecdote
than an experiment was this situation
where at the age of one and a half
a children were taken away, um,
from a really harsh orphanage where he
had no contact and brought into a home
for mentally retarded
women are these women,
gave them plenty of contact and cuddling
and apparently from what we know
brought them back to normal.
Yeah.
And this is all I want to talk about,
about the emotions we feel towards our
kin to protect children and towards their
parents. Um, any questions or thoughts?
Yes.
Children in pretty chilly.
Um, it's a good question. Do Children
orphanages comfort each other? Um,
I don't know.
The situation probably wouldn't be there.
The problem is children in orphanages
who are in these terrible situation,
that'd be babies and very young and
they wouldn't be thrown together in
situations where they
could comfort each other.
It's a really interesting question.
What if it was a situation where children
were raised without a support of cloth?
Mother adol they'll be able
to pick them up and hold them,
but they could play amongst
themselves and support each other.
I don't know the answer to that.
Yes. Yes. Is there evidence on that? Yes.
Yes.
Um, bands or is there is evidence
as it, as everybody knows
that I'm,
that this sort of amongst the young
support can actually help the monkey in a
told me,
somebody else had a question here.
Yes.
So what does that tell
us about the middle of
comforting with just a little
bit, you know, not that much,
right?
So this is,
this is the question is what does
that tell us about the middle ground?
So this is an extreme case,
but what do we know about the middle case?
Say Your parents, you're not raised in
a cage and not in a Romanian orphanage,
but your parents just don't pick you up
very much. They don't love you very much.
Um, there's no good evidence that
that has any effect on a person.
The problem is,
and we're going to talk about this in
much more detail in a couple of weeks,
is it's true that parents who
aren't affectionate have kids,
don't, aren't that aren't
affectionate, but it's not clear.
This is because of a genetic connection
or an environmental connection.
The one thing we do know is that in
the middle ground effects 10 not to be
dramatic.
So when you get away from extreme cases
affects our heart to see in require
careful experimental
research to tease out,
I think what it's safe to say for a lot,
for everything.
But the severe conditions is we don't
know what kind of effects there are,
but if there are effects,
they are not big and dramatic ones.
Okay.
Okay. Animals, good feelings. Animals.
Emotional attraction to their
kin is not a huge puzzle.
From an evolutionary point of
view. Evolution is driven by, um,
forces that operate on the fact of how
many genes get reproduced and replicated,
uh,
among your descendants.
So it makes sense that animals would
be wired up to care for their kids.
It would make sense that kids who
are wired up to survive would develop
attachments to their parents.
What's more of a puzzle though,
is that animals, including humans,
seem to have exquisite Lee,
complicated relationships
with non-kin in particular.
Animals are nice to non-kin. You are nice
to people that you're not related to.
A lot of examples of this. Um, animals
groom one another. You know, you go,
you pick off the lights and the bugs
off your friend, they pick it off you.
Um, they, um,
they give warning cries so I'm warning
cries all sorts of animals give warning
Christ um, you are um, I dunno,
you're like a little animal and a big
animal comes charging and say, Hey,
you know, oh, you made some sort
of cry and everybody runs away.
That very risky for you.
Um,
but you do it anyway often to protect
people. You aren't related to, um,
often animal sheer childcare and from a
cold blooded natural selection survival
of the gene point of view, you
wouldn't imagine that, you know,
if you lend me your kid for today,
I would eat them for protein and you know,
it's not my jeans. And I hear
it gives more, more for my kids.
That's not quite how it works though.
Animal share food,
in fact, that animal,
you know, hugely ugly.
The Vampire Bat shares food.
What happens is the vampire bat vampire
bats live in caves and they fly out.
And what they do is often about,
we'll strike it big. So find a horse,
for instance,
bite the Horse Pumbaa and tons
of blood and then fly back.
And what it does is it
doesn't keep it to itself,
rather it goes around the whole cave and
vomits blood into the mouth of all the
other vampire bats. So everybody
benefits. Isn't that nice?
Now what you're tempted to say is,
well,
that's really nice,
everybody benefits.
But this raises a puzzle from
evolutionary point of view. Remember, um,
animals benefit, um, more
under this situation.
And if it's animals benefit more by
working together, by working alone,
the benefits outweigh the cost.
This is known as reciprocal altruism,
meaning my behavior to you,
my good behavior to you,
my altruism for you, um, is predicated
on the idea of reciprocation.
I'll benefit from you and you imagine
how vampire bats, for instance,
why this makes sense. Um, this
is, uh, if you're a vampire,
bat is a better system when anybody's
strikes a big to feed you rather than for
anybody who strike it big, used the
blood and it spit out all the rest of it.
But here's the problem.
Here's why it's such a puzzle.
The problem is the existence of
cheaters and an economics and sociology,
these are also known as free riders.
And what a cheater or free rider does
is it takes the benefits without paying
the cost.
Imagine two genes.
Imagine one builds a vampire bat that
accepts blood from others and shares
blood.
The other gene excepts blood from
others and doesn't share blood.
In the long run be we'll actually
outproduced GNA because in fact be will be
healthy while other vampire bats get sick.
And um,
and then so the offspring will do better.
Um,
and even sharper example is
an example of warning Christ.
So gophers give warning cries.
When there's a Predator,
it is extremely adaptive to
give a warning cry, sorry.
It's really reactive to, to respond to
a warning cry. You hear a warning cry,
how crap your runaway.
It is not very adaptive
to give a warning cry.
A really good solution then is to x to
listen to warning Christ put not to give
them, you know, suppose we had a system.
It is very adaptive when
people are going to the bar,
when people buy drinks
to accept the drinks,
it is not so adaptive from the standpoint
of ones wallet to buy. People drinks.
Here's a solution except drinks,
but don't pay for drinks.
And if everybody fell to that solution,
the idea of buying around would fade.
So there's the puzzle.
Since cheating,
since a cheater in the short run can
always out when does better than a non
cheater?
How could this cooperation evolve?
How could it be an
evolutionarily stable strategy?
And the answer is cheater detection.
Um,
reciprocal altruism can only evolve if
animals are wired up to punish cheaters.
Now that requires a lot of mental
apparatus. You have to recognize cheaters,
you have to remember cheaters, and you had
to be motivated to punish cheaters. Um,
and not every animal has this
degree of complicated apparatus,
but actually we know,
um, that vampire bats do.
So in one clever study.
So there's sort of the theory says
evolutionary theory says, yeah,
I see what he's vampire bats are doing.
But you see,
and this is a case where evolution makes
a nice prediction that couldn't evolve
in less.
Bats are keeping track.
If bats aren't keeping track then the
system could never exist because the
cheaters would just take it over.
They must be watching for cheaters.
So the experiment which was done is
you are vampire bats strikes at big,
it flies back and then you
keep it as a scientist,
you keep it from giving blood to
anybody else. Then what happens?
Well, what happens is when
the other bats strike it big,
they starve the selfish bat.
Just as if we go to bars and
everybody buys around except for me.
And this happens over and over over again.
Pretty soon you're going to buy around,
but you're not going to give me one.
And so just as humans are keeping their
eyes out for people who are taking the
benefits without paying the costs.
So are other animals.
And it is argued that this
sensitivity to cheating,
there's this focus on reciprocity.
Reciprocation,
um,
plays a powerful role in the evolution
of social behavior and evolution of
social emotions. And the classic
illustration of this, um,
is the prisoner's
dilemma. Now, many of you,
I think I've seen the prisoner's dilemma
in one course or another. It shows up.
It is one of the main constructs
in the social sciences.
It shows up in cognitive science,
psychology, economics that you could, um,
the teaching fellows are passing around
something which you're not going to use
right away.
But for some of you,
this is the first time you're going to
be exposed to the prisoner's dilemma.
So let me spell it out.
Here's the idea.
You and a friend commit a crime.
You Rob a bank for instance.
For the sake of this example,
you are a prisoner to,
you get caught,
the police put you in a
little room and they say,
we want to know everything that happened.
In particular,
we want you to rat out your friend.
Now,
here are the options. And one thing
about this is nothing is hidden.
The police officer could actually print
out a copy of the prisoner's dilemma and
put it right in front of you. And when he
could say is, look, I'm your prisoner to,
you could cooperate. Um, where
you, you have two options.
You can either cooperate with your friend,
um,
you can stay silent or you could
defect or you could squeal.
But the police officer says, look,
if you let me tell you something,
if you cooperate with your
friend and he squeals on you,
you go to prison for life
and he'll walk it, walk out.
However,
if you squeal on him and he cooperates,
he's,
he keeps quiet. He'll go to prison
for life and you'll walk out.
So what do you do now on the nice side,
where you can do is you can say,
no, I'm going to be quiet.
I'm going to cooperate. Now,
if you could trust your friend
to cooperate, you're fine.
You just get a little stint in prison.
But of course your friend might
affect your friend might squeal.
Here's, here's the important
structure of the prisoner's dilemma.
No matter what you,
what your friend chooses to do,
you're better off squealing.
So suppose you're a prisoner to you,
believe your friends going to cooperate
with you. He's not going to be,
he's not going to give
the information out.
Well then your best thing
to do is squeal on him.
What if you believe he's
going to squeal on you? Well,
your best thing to do is squeal on him.
But if you could get your act together
and you could coordinate this,
you would both be quiet and
get a fairly minor penalty.
And you could see this. This
is the standard origin at
a prisoner's dilemma, why?
It's called a prisoner's dilemma. Um,
but you can see this all over the place.
So here's the logic.
The best case for you is to defect
while the other person cooperates.
The worst case is to cooperate
while other person defects.
Back to the police thing.
The best case for you is to give up all
information to other guys. Stay silent.
You cut a deal, you walk home that
day. The worst case is you're quiet.
He cuts a deal.
You go to prison for life.
But overall the best is that
each cooperate and overall
the worst for both is if
each defect and the reason
that makes this tragic is this,
regardless of what your opponent does,
it pays to defect.
But if both people to
affect both are worse off.
I'll give a couple of other examples.
Oh,
that's just to show that
there is a cartoon, of course,
Barton to the prisoner's dilemma. It
is that common. Here's the idea. I am,
I break off my wife.
We've been married for a while,
we've decided we're not going to go go
through it together anymore and we break
up, we living in separate houses
and we're starting to talk divorce.
It occurs to me, here's
me, I put that to me.
Should I get a divorce lawyer? I ask. Now,
I know divorce lawyers are
really expensive and it's
kind of difficult to get a
divorce lawyer.
But if I get a divorce lawyer,
and so neither one of us get a
divorce lawyer, we'll just do, okay.
We'll get a mediator will split the money
down in the middle. That'll be okay.
But I'm kind of tempted if I get a
divorce lawyer and she doesn't and she
doesn't, my divorce lawyer will take
everything she got. I get everything.
She loses everything. Maybe
I should be nice. Hold it.
What if she gets a divorce
lawyer and I don't?
Well then I'll lose everything.
She'll get everything.
Well, we should both get a divorce
player then, but we both do pretty badly.
Imagine where two countries,
country a country B, should I newco.
How do nuclear disarmament?
That's pretty good.
We do okay if we both countries disarmed,
you know, we live our lives, you know,
raise taxes.
We'll do whatever countries do,
but wouldn't it be cool if I build
up my weaponry and they don't?
I'll invade, take everything they
got. That's kind of tempting. Oh,
also, if I don't do anything and
they do it, Dylan, invade my country,
take everything. So we both build up
our weaponry. We both do pretty badly.
Once you start thinking
about things this way,
there's no end to the sort of notions
that could fall under the prisoner's
dilemma. Um, a good
example is a drug deal.
Suppose I want to buy
marijuana from you or um,
or refer as they call it on the street.
MMM.
So,
so I have $1,000 and from you,
I'd like to buy a ton of reefer,
so
I'm rounding up. Um, so you say wonderful.
Wonderful.
Let's meet behind the gym.
Two in the morning on Friday, and
we'll do to change. You bring $1,000.
I bring the river. All
right. Oh, cool. Okay, good.
And I think that's pretty good. Thousand
Bucks. I get to refer you 1000 bucks.
That's my name. That's okay.
That's the normal thing.
But now something occurs to me.
Nobody's going to go to the
cops if things go badly.
So instead of doing green, no
money, why don't I just bring a gun?
You come with your reefer, I stick a gun
in your face, take the reefer, go home.
Maybe I want to do that. But now I worry
because you're thinking the same thing.
So you could show up with a gun,
stick the gun in my face,
take the thousand bucks, go home,
I'll have no refer. What will I smoke?
So we both think this way.
So we both show up behind the
gym two in the morning with guns.
Well that's not as bad
for either one of us.
If if I had you had a gun,
I didn't have a gun,
but still we're both worse off then if
we could cooperate and just do the damn
trade. And that's the structure
of prisoner's dilemma.
You can only appreciate the prisoner's
dilemma by actually doing it.
So here's,
here is a new miracle equivalent
to the prisoner's dilemma.
Everybody should have a card in front
of you, a file card. If you don't,
if you didn't get a card,
a piece of paper will do just as well.
Please write on one side,
cooperate and on the other side defect.
And then please find a partner
with whom to play one game.
This is a one shot game.
Yeah,
one of you is player one,
the player on the right most side from
my right could be played or one the other
one is player to do.
You each have a partner.
If you have three people you could
cluster together and do two and then two
and just think and is actually best if
you've never met or spoken to the person
you're about to deal with.
Um,
and the game is when I say go simply
show the person your choice to be clear.
If you are a player one and you cooperate
and player two cooperates as well,
you each get $3. If you are a player, one
of you cooperate, we'll play to Defax.
Player two gets $5.
You get bupkis um,
and so on,
on three,
just show the card to your opponent,
to your person you're
playing with one, two, three.
Okay.
People in this room,
people in this room cooperated.
How many cooperated?
How many defected?
Okay, how many people
are now $5 richer? Okay.
How many of you got nothing?
Okay,
so you're learning, you're learning that
the person next to you is really an sob.
Now
person next to you and you get to play
again and you get to play five games in a
row.
Play five games in a row and keep score.
You just show it to each other. Record
the numbers, show it, show it, show it,
show it.
Go now.
Anybody here?
$25.
Yes.
so you,
that's 20,
20,
21. Okay. It's good.
It's good. It's a really,
as a measure
of honesty. Um, anybody win 20 or more?
15 or more. 15, 14 or less.
Anybody do five or less?
Good. You're a good person. It's
good. It's good. You played at him,
bad person. Um, it's not,
it's not really about about
good or bad. Um, there was a
great game once. It's a simple game.
Um, but there was a great game,
a great famous competition a
long time ago, but 20 years ago,
set up by the great computer scientist,
Robert Axelrod,
and he put together a competition where
people brought in computer programs to
play this game.
To play the prisoner's dilemma and there
were 63 competitors and these computer
programs were incredibly, some of
them were very simple, always be nice,
always be,
always cooperate,
always defect somewhere elegant
prime numbers, solutions and,
and prototype responses,
genetic algorithms crafted to to,
to to figure out what the other
person was doing and sussed him out.
But the winner,
the winner was developed by Anatol
Rapoport and Anatol Rapoport actually died
about a month ago, um,
at quite an old age,
a great scientist.
What was interesting about this was
he was the winner with this program,
but this program was also one of the
simplest, it may well be the simplest,
it was called tit for tat and it worked.
Very simple.
Took four lines of basic code.
The first time you meet a new program,
cooperate the first
time you meet somebody,
be nice after that.
Do on each trial.
What the other program
did on a previous trial,
this beat 62 others.
And here's why it has certain
beautiful features. It starts friendly.
Remember, the best longterm solution
is everybody's busy, everybody's nice.
It starts off nice, but you
can't, it's not a sucker.
If you screw with it, it will, it
will defect back on an external.
It is however forgiving
you want to get nice with it.
Be Nice. If you're nice, it'll,
it'll be nice back at you later on.
As also transparent, nothing complicated
about it and that's actually important.
It's not merely, that is not
a sucker and forgiving. Um,
more to the point, um,
it is, um, it is you,
you could tell it's not a sucker and you
could tell it's forgiving and this very
powerful algorithm learn to cooperate
even in a situation and help you learn to
make it out the best.
Even in a situation where there's
a risk of cheating and betrayal.
Some psychologists have argued that our
emotions correspond to the different
permutations on the prisoner's dilemma.
We like people who cooperate with us.
This motivates us to be
nice to them in the future.
Much as a tit for tat algorithm says,
if you're nice to me now,
I'll be nice to you back.
We don't like being screwed with.
We feel anger and distrust towards those
portrayals that motivates us to betray
or avoid them in the future.
And we feel bad when we were traced
somebody who cooperates with us.
This motivates us to behave
better in the future. Um,
you can break down the cells
of the prisoner's dilemma
in terms of emotions that
they give rise to.
I didn't experiment last night with
my seven year old and my 10 year old.
I explained to them
the prisoner's dilemma.
I didn't give the divorce lawyer
example, but um, but, and I,
and we gave him a big thing
of chocolate chips and,
and the good chocolate
chips we had to good yet.
And we had to matrix and we had them play.
Now what they did is so interesting,
but what's interesting is they
were furious at each other.
One of them, the younger boy was
kept being betrayed by the older boy,
including tricks. Like you'd say,
okay, let's both cooperate. Okay, okay.
And you cooperate, defect. And,
and,
and the response was anger though.
Not Actually guilt on the
part of the other, but rage.
Um, and we see these sorts of
things all the time in real life.
You're familiar to prisoner's dilemma,
but there's another game which you
might not be familiar with. Um,
it's called the ultimatum game. How many
of you have encountered ultimatum game?
Okay, some of you very simple. Choose
a partner is a very simple game.
When the economists study this,
they actually do this with real money.
I do not have real money to let you
do this too. Um, one of you is a,
one of you is be the one on the
right most from this side is a,
the other one is B.
Here's a very simple rule.
I like a to turn to be and make an offer.
A has $10.
You can give me any amount you
choose from that $10 from $1 to $10.
B can do only one thing.
B can accept it.
If you accept it and you agree to
take home, no money and a keeps,
whatever's left or rejected. If
you reject it, you get nothing.
Nobody gets anything. Everybody.
Claire's. So A's going to say,
I'll give you so and so dollars. People
say, okay, in which case be walks away.
If so and so dollars
or I'm an a walks away,
whatever arrest or B could say reject
in which case nobody gets anything.
So this game cards in two steps.
The first thing I like a to
turn to be and make your offer.
Don't beat, doesn't do
anything yet. Make your offer.
Your offer should be one word.
People aren't explaining their offer.
Make your offer. Okay? Stage two.
Stage two do not negotiate.
Then I see people waving her
hands in this complicated.
It should be a number from one to 10.
A positive integer.
Now B,
I like B to say one word and you could
say it really loud on three except or
reject. One. Two, three.
Wow.
How many people accepted?
Anybody rejected? Good. Okay.
How many people offered $10.
How many people are
for more than $5? Okay. I
don't even got offered $1.
Okay. When you offered
$1, did you accept? Yup.
Anybody else offer $1? When you offered
$1 did you partner? Except, Yup.
Okay. Um, how many people
offered either four or $5.
Okay.
Um,
this is an interesting game because the
person who offered who accepted $1 was
being rational. $1 is
better than no dollars. Um,
so the psychology of human rationality
is such that that from a logical point of
view, you should reason
$1 is better than nothing.
I rational poaching should accept
$1 and because we're smart,
a should offer $1, but not
many of you offered a $1. Why?
Because you know,
people are not purely rational people
even in a one shot game won't accept
unfair distributions.
They'll reject them just out of spite.
And so you need to offer more.
And this has been studied from
a neuro economic point of view,
which basically provides
neuroanatomical evidence that people,
if you offered them $1,
they get really,
nobody likes to be offered a dollar.
Now there's a more general moral here,
which is actually an interesting surprise
of some relevance to everyday life.
I rational person is easily exploited
a rational person.
So responses to provocations to
assaults will always be measured and
appropriate. If you know I'm rational and
you're in a sharing situation with me,
you could say to me, hey, here's
a dollar. Hey mister rational,
a dollar is better than nothing,
okay, because I'm rational. Um,
similarly you could mess with me because
you could like harass me in all sorts
of ways.
Take things that I own as long as you
reason that a rational person wouldn't
start a fuss about this,
there is some advantage to being
irrational to having a temper.
Because if you have a temper and
you're known to be irrational,
people are forced by dint of your
irrationality to treat you better. Um,
who am I going to take from the person
who's extremely reasonable or the person
who has a here trigger temper? Well,
I'm going to focus, I'm going to,
I'm going to pick on a reasonable person
cause the unreasonable person might do
unreasonable things.
And this is faintly paradoxical,
but often to be irrational or at
least to have a reputation for mile
irrationality gives you an edge.
Now,
this is in focus of provocation,
but this is also been presented in
a theory of why people fall in love.
Suppose you're choosing
who to devote your life to.
And as a matter of huge trust,
we're going to raise kids together.
It's very important for you that I
don't leave and I'm very irrational.
So I say to you,
we should make and have children because
I find you the most attractive of
everybody who was available that
I've met so far. I'm very irrational.
And as so long as this continues
to be the case, we'll be together.
Well that's reasonable and rational.
But wouldn't you rather be with somebody
who was head over heels in love,
head over heels in love is irrational,
but it's also within certain parameters
in deray because the irrationality of
the person means you could
trust them more in the long run.
Just like their rationality of somebody
who has a temper means you don't mess
with them as much.
The studies have been done more with
regard to violence, then we'll fluff.
And in fact,
the irrationality that the
benefits of irrational violence,
um, have been translated in terms of, um,
the study of homocide and other crimes.
A Daly and Wilson describe
the cause of murder.
Most murder is not caused
by reasonable provocation.
Most murder is not
rational in this response.
Most murder is generated by
insult, curse, petty and fraction.
But this is not crazy irrationality.
It's adaptive irrationality,
Daly and Wilson point out and chronically
feuding and warning societies and
essential manual manly virtue is the
capacity for violence to turn the other
cheek is not saintly but stupid or
contempt. Contemptible Lee weak.
If I show myself a rash or irrational
person when picked on or harassed,
I'll be known as somebody you
can pick on and harass. Um,
and in fact,
it turns out even in a modern world,
this is from a New York Times I
just picked up a year ago today. Um,
and the point is that the violence is
due to people disrespecting each other or
giving a dirty look. And you might
think, isn't that irrational?
But it's not irrational circumstances
where people live together in an
environment where you have to deal with
each other over and over again and often
where there's not much support,
um,
by the police as in the
cases they talked about here.
What's particularly interesting is this
sort of importance of a reputation for
violence differs from culture to culture.
And I've been talking so far in this
class and in fact so far in this course,
um,
about universals,
but things that are built in things that
show up across humans and other animals.
Um,
I want to turn now and end this lecture
by talking a little bit about a cultural
difference and as a
psychologically interesting
cultural difference with regard
to the emotions and it's
built around a difference. Um,
turning around what sociologists
call cultures of honor. Um,
a culture of honor has certain properties
you can rely on the law and I'm,
and it has resources that are easily
taken and sociologists have argued that
when those conditions are met,
it becomes important to develop a
reputation provile and retaliation that
becomes important.
Um,
examples of culture of honors
include Scottish highlanders,
Mussai warriors better when
tradesmen in western cowboys,
all cases where there's resources such
as cattle that are vulnerable and easily
taken,
but you can't count on calling nine one
one and having people kind of help you.
But the culture of honor
that's been studied the most
by modern psychologists is
an American south.
Um,
this was settled by herdsmen and
traditionally has less centralized legal
control.
So sociologists say the American south
is more of a culture of honor then the
American north. But how do you know,
I mean, what does that do? We're,
we're interested in this class
in claims about psychology.
So it took,
um,
Richard Nisbett and Doug Cohen to
study cultures of honors and look at
differences and they found some
interesting differences. Um,
gun laws tend to be more
permissive in the southern, in,
in the American south and American north.
Um,
corporal punishment and capital
punishment at tend to be more approved of
attitudes towards the military are
more positive in a questionnaire.
Studies people are more forgiving
towards cultures of honor.
Somebody insults my woman and
I punched him in the face. Um,
this is considered less bad in
American south than the American north.
There's a higher rate of violence,
but only in certain circumstances.
The streets at American south as a rule
are not more dangerous than the American
north. The differences, there's a higher
rate of crimes that are crimes of honor,
such as, for instance, if somebody
breaks into my house, me shooting them,
or if somebody insults me,
me killing him.
Now this is sort of survey studies.
So it has been,
and Cohen didn't,
one of the more interesting
psychological studies I've ever heard of,
and they did this at, I'm just
sorry, this is this button. Wilson.
They did this with University
of Michigan undergraduates. Um,
they did a subject pool thing
like you're doing now and on it,
your demographic information was
listed and what they did was they took
white males who are not
Hispanic and not Jewish.
That was your sample culture of honor
is a phenomena limited to males and they
wanted to make us sort of a clean study.
So they want to focus,
get a homogeneous samples.
So not Hispanic, not Jewish,
and they provoke them.
And the provocation was genius.
What he did was they said,
they brought people into,
into the psychology building as you'd be
brought into Kirtland or sss or Dunham.
And they said they had somebody go
in, there's a desk, and he said, yeah,
go down the hall for the experiment.
There's a hallway.
And then you walk through the hallway
and walking the other direction.
At that moment,
a graduate student,
a male graduate student would start to
walk and he's holding some files and what
he does is he bumps to person,
looks at them and says, asshole,
and keep walking.
Now to be fair,
the graduate students survived
bumping into like hundreds of mails,
calling them assholes and, and then
walking through fights did not break out.
Nobody was shot,
but then they brought them in.
Now went into a room and they were
tested and it turned out that,
um,
that there were differences in
the stress response. On average,
males from American south showed higher
hormone response and stress response,
then males in American north increases
in testosterone and cortisol.
Um, there's also differences in
later behavior. Um, the mirror,
the people suggest that
they were made angry. Um,
they gave differences in fill in the
blank questions. For instance, um,
you know, I, I don't remember the
examples, but it's examples like, uh,
like John went to the store and bought
a blank and then, and then, you know,
and the north end of the
say, and by, you know,
an apple and a southern state and AK 47
to kill that freaking graduate students.
Now again,
the Americans have,
people in American south were not
overall more violent than American north,
but they worn more sensitive
to provocations of honor. Now,
when they gave this lecture a few years
ago, um, uh, southern student, uh,
contacted me afterwards and said that
she felt that picking out the southern
minority at Yale was to some
regard offensive and that
people say things at Yale
about southerners, American
southerner's that they would never say,
but any other minority group.
So there's two points I want to make
regarding this. One is of course,
these are average differences,
um,
not every northerner and south and
would differ along these lines.
But another one is I
think the effect is real,
but it's not entirely clear
that it reflects poorly on
the cultures of honor as
opposed to other cultures.
So Nisbet for instance,
is himself a southerner and he points
out that, that when he went to the north,
he was most astonished
by how rude people are.
And this is because the North American
north is not particularly a culture of
honor.
Um,
and so and so there's less proper behavior
towards other people because there
was no fear of retaliation
or response. Um, moreover,
um, the culture of honor of
honor virtues like, um, honor,
loyalty, courage and self
reliance or on the face of it,
not necessarily bad.
Thanks. In any case, um,
this is an interesting example of how
there's an evolutionary background,
um,
but culture modifies and shifts it
in different ways more generally.
Um,
I've suggested over the last couple of
lectures that emotions like fear to love
you have to,
your children anger,
gratitude are not aberrations
or noise in the system. Rather,
they're exquisitely complicated
motivational systems
that are crafted to deal
with the natural and social environment.
Um,
and we know this only from an analysis
that starts from an evolutionary
approach. So to bring us
back to Darcy Thompson, um,
everything is the way it
is because it got that way.
And your reading response
for this week is, is that,
and, um, and I wish you good luck on an
exam on Wednesday. I'll see you there.